while we start this broadcast with
intrigue in berlin german news magazine
der spiegel is reporting that a russian
diplomat's body was found outside
moscow's embassy in berlin last october
news of the discovery has only emerged
now the russian embassy is located in
central berlin close to brandenburg gate
the spiegel is reporting that germany's
security services believe the diplomat
worked for the russian security services
christo graves krotzev is a reporter at
bellingcat that's a collective of
investigative journalists which has also
been reporting on this story along with
their spiegel magazine thank you so much
for joining us what exactly have you
learned about the circumstances behind
the death of this man
what we found out is that approximately
10 days ago on the 19th of
october at 7 20 in the morning police
guarding the uh building or the the
premises where the
embassy's house discovered a young man
or 35 year old man approximately 35 by
the looks of him lying on the pavement
and
they tried to success resuscitate him
they brought in an emergency service but
it was too late he was dead
declared that on
on the ground um they tried then to
get the russian authorities from the
embassy to surrender the body for an
autopsy but that was declined
by invocation of the diplomatic status
of the person who apparently was a
diplomat
and then the body was given back to the
russian embassy and was flown as far as
we understand either the next day or the
day after to russia without an autopsy
uh what we discovered in the meantime
was interestingly the identity of this
man we're not going to name him because
balance doesn't name
victims but we discovered that his first
of all he was a second secretary at the
embassy he had served as a third
secretary at the vienna representation
of russia to the united nations until
june 2019 when he was moved to the
berlin embassy
and we discovered that his father is a
high-ranking fsb general in fact
one of the top five people at the fsb
he's in charge of something called the
unit for the protection of the
constitutional order of russia and that
is a very
important part of the fsb because this
is essentially the political police
it's the entity that has been targeting
tracking tailing surveilling and
as we found out last year poisoning
dissidents in russia and that's exactly
the entity that detailed
and organized the poisoning of alexey
navalny according to our reporting
and that is also the entity that has
been tailed many many other opposition
figures such as vladimir murzah and even
the poet dmitry bikov who was poisoned
in unclear circumstances in 2018.
so um yeah that's the father right what
we found out was that german authorities
believed the sun was also an fsb asset
or an fsb uh
officer undercover but we haven't been
able to prove that at this point right
fsb of course stands for russian
intelligence services just for the
viewers who might not know it's taken
some time for news of the death of this
man to emerge why do you think that is
well first of all it doesn't
automatically get into the statistics
for deaths in germany when it's an
embassy diplomat because because of the
immunity it really is not reflected in
the general flow of information so
homicide detectives in the german police
would not have received this information
unless the german embassy or the russian
embassy voluntarily required an
investigation so this is one of the
reasons uh but i believe that also there
has been some confusion within the
german uh security apparatus about what
exactly this meant was this
sort of a
foul play was this death because of some
internal power play within the russian
embassy and maybe the security services
or was this a completely
accidental death um
[Music]
in mundane circumstances so i think it
took some time for the german
authorities to figure out whether this
is something to even talk about
all right christo grotzeph is reporter
ed bellencat and he has been following
the circumstances of the diplomat that
was found dead in front of the russian
embassy sir thank you for joining us
thank you very much